buongiorno a tutti sono federico morello
ho 18 anni mi occupo di banda larga
porto internet dove non c'è
oggi parliamo di coraggio
lui è uno che di coraggio né alla sua
uscita si chiama bergreen se un pazzo
scatenato che si fa a lanciare in luoghi
sperduti e cerca di vivere come può
ecco cosa c'entra come non molto ve lo
dico io è già tanto se riesco a
sopravvivere stanotte nella camera
dell'hotel però le nostre due avventure
sebbene diverse hanno due elementi in
comune
il primo è l'andare fuori sentiero il
cercare un'altra strada una strada
diversa
il secondo è uno stretto legame con la
lumaca la differenza è che lui le
lumache sele magna vive crude e io
invece mi limito a combatterla e
dell'umore che sebbene lumache digitale
infatti abitavo in un paesino molto
piccolo nel friuli occidentale dove non
c'era alcun tipo di collegamento
internet veloce nessun tipo di banda
larga
nemmeno le chiavette 3g funzionavano
ecco potete immaginare quale fosse la
faccia di chi anche solo dovesse
controllare la propria e mail era
davvero una situazione disastrosa
un giorno tra i 13 ei 14 anni decisi che
è che non andava bene così che dovevo
provare almeno a fare qualcosa e quindi
quasi come se fosse un semplice
esercizio di italiano scrissi al sindaco
caro sindaco voglio la banda larga
spiegami perchè io non ce l'ho egli è
tutto il resto del mondo si spiegami
perchè non posso vedere un video su
youtube ma anche perché non solo
l'officina non può inviare i dati alla
motorizzazione e siamo solo noi ad
essere scollegati in questo modo qui il
sindaco dapprima rispose tutto contento
che carino 14 anni federico
grande siamo contenti di avere un
concittadino così continua così bravo ma
non chiederci di fare qualcosa per
l'amor di dio perché stiamo aspettando
il progetto regionale
poi dopo che io contattai l'assessore
regionale e deb il via libera a cercare
un'altra strada per portare la banda
larga nel mio paese cambia un pò i toni
e rispose con grazie all ennesima
lettera ma non romperci più le scatole
ciao non ti rispondiamo più in quel
momento il mio compitino l'avevo fatto
poteva gettare la spugna
avrei voluto gettare la spugna invece mi
feci coraggio e decisi di saltare nel
vuoto di fare un salto nel vuoto mi
iscrissi a un'associazione nazionale
anti digital divide
studiai telecomunicazioni all'interno di
questa associazione ed ecco il salto nel
vuoto
mi ritrovai a 14 anni ad essere il
responsabile regionale senza sapere cosa
volesse dire fare il responsabile
regionale di un'associazione del genere
eppure questa esperienza mi permise di
studiare di vedere il tutto da un'altra
prospettiva
e credetemi forse coraggio e anche non
sentirsi sempre impreparati e
focalizzarsi su un obiettivo certo
studiare cercare una soluzione concreta
un fabbisogno reale ma buttarsi non
aspettare non pensare di essere sempre
impreparati e quindi mi accorsi
riguardando il panorama di quel problema
che in realtà ero di fronte a due sponde
di un canyon
da una parte si trovava la pubblica
amministrazione dall'altra si trovavano
i provider e gli operatori o in generale
un processo di digitalizzazione
ecco in quel caso la pia e tutt'oggi
purtroppo molto spesso non hanno a un
necessario anche solo per capire il
problema e si ritrova a finanziare
progetti progetti tampone che non
risolvono niente in realtà ma spendono
soldi
dall'altra parte invece ci sono i
provider soprattutto quelli medio
piccoli che potrebbero con la loro
tecnologia a portare una soluzione ma
non hanno i dati del territorio non
hanno dati reali che vengono dal
territorio non sanno che quella zona
industriale realmente scoperta che
mancano competitors in un'area magari
piccola ma dove
rivale non sanno anche semplicemente
qual è la collina migliore dove
installare un'antenna ad esempio
riducendo i costi e coprendo la maggior
area possibile quello che feci è creare
un piano di copertura ripresentarlo in
comune e andare sostanzialmente a
guidare una diciamo joint ventures
pubblico privata dove davo consulenza
tecnica alla pubblica amministrazione e
territoriale ai provider e grazie a
questa joint ventures pochi mesi dopo
grazie a questa antenna riuscì a coprire
tutta la pedemontana friulana offrendo
un servizio molto concorrenziale ea
basso costo
mi chiesi perché non continuare e quindi
fonda i frullati di un movimento
autonomo con l'acqua con il quale
continuare a portare banda larga in
altri piccoli paesini friulani è
tutt'oggi e anche qui magari c'è un po
di coraggio visti i tempi come
consulente non faccio altro che cercare
di far dialogare la pubblica
amministrazione con altri player che
usano un altro linguaggio andando a fare
una sorta di ri design dei progetti dei
processi interni alla pubblica
amministrazione in ottica
digitalizzazione ecco come abbiamo già
detto diventa e venne nominato alfiere
della repubblica perché iniziare a
girare l'italia a spiegare che internet
non è una cosa difficile è un non è una
cosa da detti lavoro dai lavori è una
cosa facile è facile come fare il caffè
chiunque può fare un buon caffè senza
sapere nulla di termodinamico di come
effettivamente funziona una moka l'altra
cosa che cercare di fare è stata quella
di parlare i miei coetanei a chi ha la
mattina viene a scuola con me per
cercare di dare coraggio
qui sono parla automatica di fronte a
cinquemila studenti e dove cerco di far
capire che in realtà non ci sono
eccezioni io sono esattamente come loro
la vera
la vera soluzione per cambiare le cose
alla portata di tutti basta focalizzarsi
e avere una buona soluzione reale ha un
problema sentito basta avere coraggio
insomma poco tempo fa un altro salto nel
vuoto preso il computer e scrissi alla
vicepresidente della commissione europea
che ha la delega l'agenda digitale
cruise di sì
si vede che con le letterine fin dai
tempi di babbo natale insomma qualche
dimestichezza ce l'aveva cara la
vicepresidente cruz questa l'agenda
digitale europea secondo me andrebbe
fatto questo andrebbe fatto quello e
questa è la mia storia la crus che non
solo il vicepresidente della commissione
ma è anche una signora che va alle
riunioni informali con un angry birds
rosa gigante in parte
non solo mi rispose non solo rimase
colpita dalla mia storia ma crea un un
advisor di un gruppo di consulenti under
35 gli young advisor che ora la
coordinano nell'andare a studiare le
policy europee in tutti i problemi
dell'agenda digitale europea
ecco questa è la mia nuova avventura
non so bene dove mi porterà è molto
diversa sia da quella precedente che da
quella di bear grylls però in questi
anni ho capito una cosa il vero coraggio
il vero coraggio che dobbiamo cercare
che dobbiamo avere dentro tutti noi per
cambiare le cose per cambiare questo
paese
in realtà è il coraggio di fare e il
coraggio di fare se ci pensiamo
questo non è altro che è l'insegnamento
di un maestro che conosciamo tutti mi
piace sempre concludere così che non
diceva altro che questo fare o non fare
grazie mille